[موسيقى]
علاقه العرب بالابلي ونجوم السماء علاقه
استدلاليه وهم يستدلون على سلوكيات الابل
وعلى حركات النجوم على دخول الفصول
والمواسم افلا ينظرون الى الابل كيف خلقت
والى السماء كيف رفعت وهم يعرفون بدايه
البرد مع شروق نجوم سنام الناقه بالجهه
الشماليه الشرقيه قبائل الفاجر وهذه
المجموعه النجميه سلاما ناقه هي التي تدل
على نجم القطب المسمى عند العامه بنجم
الجدي الجدي خلوه فوق ورث المطيع
سهيل اليماني نمشي يلا على كليه وبالقدر
ناصر
و8
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وخلال هذه الايام يبدا ميزان درجات
الحراره بالانخفاض التدريجي تباعا مع مرور
الايام وهذا اماره وعلامه على قرب بدايه
الشتاء والبرد الفعلي الجياد لا يتحقق الا
اذا وصلت الشمس الى اقصى ميل لها ناحيه
الجنوب بما يسمى بالمنقلب الشتوي من 21
ديسمبر وطالع وحين ذاك تبدا تهب علينا
الرياح الشماليه البارده ان الذي يرتدي
شيئا بهمته يلقاه لو حاربته الانس والجن
تقصد الى قمم الاشياء تدركها تجري الرياح
كما ارادت لها
السفن
[موسيقى]